quand on dit de vous secrète est-ce que
ça vous vous sentez concerné totalement
totalement c'est à dire que
je dirais qu'il y a un grand secret des
choses qu'on ne livre pas des choses
qu'on ne dit pas des choses qui sortent
malgré nous parce que dans chacun de mes
rôles il y a forcément des résonances
dans dans ma vie dans ce que j'ai vécu
dans dans mes amours dans dans mes
révoltes dans mais
le grand secret qui compose mon être qui
est celui de la de de
l'enfance de la toute petite enfance
jusqu'à maintenant
il est intact il est
il est on construit sa vie d'adulte sur
son enfant ça c'est vraiment le fond de
moi je crois je crois qu'on ne peut pas
faire autrement il y a des choses c'est
impliquer d'autres gens qui eux n'ont
pas demandé à ce qu'on dévoile leur vie